one pill can kill that's the message
from metro police as they recognize
national fentanyl awareness day the
synthetic drug is a serious problem
across the country the number of
overdoses continue to climb from adults
to teens and even children this lethal
drug has gained popularity many are
diagnosed with severe pain and
prescribed it legally but it's when
people misuse the drug that overdoses
are likely to occur this year there have
been 413 overdose deaths in clark county
126 of them being fentanyl related dr
karuna of nevada mental health says it's
alarming how many fentanyl cases he's
seen
but with fentanyl i have seen ages 12
and up it's going to give you a much
bigger height so you're going to go back
to the drug dealer asking for the same
thing now if you don't adjust your the
quantity that you use it can cause your
respiratory system to shut down
numbers for clark county last year were
even higher there were
871 overdose deaths 248 of them were
fentanyl related
and fentanyl is a chemical based drug
that is 50 to 100 times stronger than
morphine according to the cdc only two
milligrams of fentanyl is considered a
potentially lethal dose last year over
100 thousand people in the u.s died from
drug overdoses 67 percent of those
deaths involved fentanyl